John Kramer is back with a brand new set
of death traps and nefarious intentions
so here's everything you need to know
before watching sore X
horror movies aren't just reserved for
the spooky season with freaky films
popping up all year round but there is
something about a horror flick being
released around Halloween that gives it
a particularly special feel luckily for
gorehounds sorex will start the scary
celebration with a blood-soaked bang as
it's hitting theaters on September 29
2023 interestingly saw X finds itself
sandwiched between quite a few
noteworthy horror titles it'll be
following in the wake of the nun too
what is coming out before other creepy
flicks such as the Exorcist believer and
Five Nights at Freddy's basically
Halloween season 2023 is going to be an
absolute treat for anyone wanting to
celebrate at the theater and saw extra
sure to deliver the goods when it kicks
off the frightful festivities we know
the film is actually going to be
something of a prequel taking place
after the original Saw movie but before
the events of saw 2. that means we'll be
following John Kramer during his final
days battling cancer and searching for
some sort of miracle cure John's
desperate Nation will take him to Mexico
but he's hoping to sign up for an
experimental medical procedure
unfortunately John finds out there's no
actual cure the people making lofty
promises or con artists and there's no
hope for Jon's Health below the border
of course now that the jigsaw killer has
traveled all this way he isn't going to
waste the opportunity to murder some
people now is he furious at a scammers
for taking advantage of hopeless people
Jon decides it's time to play a game
soon enough the folks who lored John to
Mexico with Promises of Salvation will
find themselves trapped in a hell of
jigsaw's making and punish for their
sins
going into saw X fans of the series
wanted to know only one thing but Tobin
Bell reprise his role as John Kramer the
good news is Belle is indeed coming back
remarking on his return the franchise
producers expressed excitement and
Belle's return and mentioned how the
John Kramer character is a major part of
the franchise's success director Kevin
gruter agreed with this sentiment
telling Empire that saw eggs would focus
on jigsaw more than any other film in
the series we'll also see quite a few
new faces populating the screen with The
Talented cast including the likes of
Steven brand Michael Beach Renata Vaca
Paulette Hernandez Joshua okamoto
Octavia inohosa and sanova makodi Lund
but will we see any former saw Stars
return alongside Tobin Bell it's
entirely possible Shawnee Smith is
definitely returning as John Kramer
Apprentice Amanda young and for a while
there was a rumor that Carrie Elwes
could return a serial killer Dr Lawrence
Gordon unfortunately for fans Elvis told
scream rant in April 2020 E3 I have no
comment one way or the other about that
franchise I really can't speak to it I'm
happy for the filmmakers that they
continue to make money and that it seems
to be a financial bonus for them I
really can't speak to it because I'm not
really involved anymore
director Kevin cruter is no stranger to
the saw franchise as he Helms 2009's saw
six and 2010's saw 3D well those were
his first two feature film direct Troy
your Pursuits he's followed them up with
three more horror Thrillers Jezebel
visions and jackals of course he isn't
the only saw Alum working behind the
scenes Peter Goldfinger and Josh
stolberg have penned the screenplay and
their credits include both spiral and
jigsaw proving they are incredibly
familiar with the nefarious games and
sadistic challenges of the saw franchise
to hear grutet tell it saw X is going to
be his greatest contribution to the
series yet back in February 2023 when
shooting wrapped on the movie crew Tech
gave fans an update on the site formerly
known as Twitter saying it was one of
the most rewarding and epic experiences
of my life crew turd went on to say that
he wanted to use sore X as a title for
the new movie for Die Hard fans gruted
promised the film would get back to the
core of the franchise and focus on John
Kramer fans was after decide for
themselves if so X lives up to gruta's
enthusiasm
it might be hard to remember the last
time there was a new Saw movie because
the last time the franchise came to the
big screen it delivered a spin-off story
2021 spiral from the book of Saw told
the story of detective Zeke Banks
searching for a serial killer clearly
inspired by jigsaw despite all the
deviously deadly traps on display in
spiral is directed insisted it wasn't a
Saw movie speaking to the Au review he
said this is not the ninth film in the
saw franchise there easily could be a
saw 9 that follows jigsaw saw X seems to
prove bowsman's remark completely wrong
it implies that spiral was a Saw movie
and completely avoids picking up where
jigsaw left off at the same time sore X
is jumping back in time all the way back
to the early 2000s when John Kramer is
still alive and wreaking havoc so it's
safe to say we won't be seeing detective
banks in this outing it's disappointing
since the twisty ending of spiral left
fans with a serious Cliffhanger
undoubtedly there will be many fans
wondering what would have happened next
in detective bank's journey and if if he
would have finally got revenge of what
Emerson did if that's the case what was
the point of spiral leaving things so
open-ended in the first place it seems
likely that Spyro was meant to kick off
a new era for the saw franchise having
from the book of soreness title clearly
set spiral apart from the rest of the
series and implied that there were more
stories like it to Town the plan might
have been to expand on detective bank's
story and to look at more serial killers
inspired by jigsaw's Legacy that plan
didn't work out because the numbers
didn't support it spiral completely
bombed at the box office in its opening
weekend which definitely dumped cold
water and the potential for spiral 2.
now that sorex has taken the series back
to its roots the book of Saw might
officially be closed where I thought the
jigsaw killer was dead yeah but if it's
another copycat it's gonna be a future
it might come as a surprise that saw
axes traveling back in time to the early
2000s but it really shouldn't the horror
genre is well known for taking the
occasional odd left turn after a Series
has been kicking around for a long time
after we sent adjacent to space
everything was on the table fans of this
particular franchise should already be
used to chronological Shenanigans for
one thing Saw 3 and saw 4 happen
simultaneously and the viewer only
realizes it later piecing together the
entire saw franchise timeline involves
more than just watching the movies in
order many characters including the
all-inforcing John Kramer have their
backstories explained in flashback
sequences only after they've hung around
for several movies there's only one
reason that sorex is going so far back
in the timeline and fans will probably
agree it's a good one John Kramer the
original jigsaw died all the way back in
Saw 3. since then the franchise has
included him in flashbacks and prequel
stories or mostly following copycat
Killers saw X is bringing the franchise
back to where it started by setting its
story in the past and letting John
Kramer return to the spotlight for real
it may be good to know that sorex is an
experienced hands but regardless of
who's working on the movie behind the
camera fans are showing up for the Manus
on screen Tobin Bell helped bring jigsaw
to life in the original saw and he's
been the core of the franchise ever
since Bella's been in every Saw movie
except for 2021 spiral and he's clearly
excited to get a chance to return to the
character in an interview with build
Bell talked about what has kept him so
engaged with the character for the past
two decades he's got uh
a huge Dimension as a character he's a
bit of a philosopher Bell added that
he'd always be willing to play a
character that interested him as much as
jigsaw he also talked about the
potential for sore X to introduce the
character to audiences who were too
young to see the original saw and as a
media sequels in theaters If there
really is a huge influx of new fans saw
X will be just the beginning of a new
slate of Saw movies
there are many words that could
accurately describe John Kramer but Hiro
definitely isn't one of them as jigsaw
Jonas killed more people than anyone can
count and he's developed some of the
most gruesome ways to murder people that
the world has ever seen despite that saw
extra seemed to be putting Jon into the
position of a typical horror movie hero
in the movie Jon goes to Mexico City to
seek specialized treatment for his
terminal cancer the people who treat him
are scammers who want to steal his money
by convincing him their medical
professionals when Jon realizes that
he's been ripped off he sets about
punishing the scammers with his usual
assortments of horrifying traps whether
or not that premise goes far enough to
justify Jon's brutal murders it's up to
the fans but saw X goes out of its way
to make Jon the front man of the movie
speaking about the film at a fan panel
Midsummer scream 2023 producer orenkulis
said John Kramer is absolutely the
protagonist in this movie The Producer
confirmed that what John experiences
makes him the hero of the film maybe
anti-hero would be a more accurate term
but kulis's point is important fans have
been dying to see more John Kramer
finally have a movie where he's a real
lead character
2024 marks the 20th anniversary of the
first Saw movie directed by James Juan
saw caught the attention of so many
horror fans because of its No Holds
Barred approach to on-screen violence
and this remarkable twist ending the
franchise has never exactly been a
critical darling but it kept filling
theaters so the series continued but
Sora seemed better days we've come a
long way since the yearly releases of
the late 2000s nowadays Saw movies are
few and far between neon guaranteed to
be successes spyworld had such an
abysmal box office performance and some
were wondering if it meant the franchise
was finally dead so X proves that
there's still some room for the series
to keep going clearly the people
responsible for making Saw movies still
believe in them Tobin Bell is still
excited by the characters and producers
and directors are willing to put time
and money into making a new movie on the
other hand saw X could end up being a
swan song for the series one way or
another the future of the entire
franchise rests on how well saw X is
received when it finally debuts oh yes
yeah
There Will Be Blood
what's in a name
thorax might seem like an obvious title
choice but there's actually a little bit
of depth to the name it seemingly
confirms that spiral was the ninth Saw
movie regardless of what his director
had to say but this latest installment
isn't taking a cue from Fast X to this
title either instead saw X is borrowing
a title formula from the franchise's
early days to make it loud and clear
that John Kramer has returned and saw is
back in fighting form and saw was just
starting every movie in this series got
a Roman numeral after the title that
finally changed with 2010's Saw 3D which
made an ill-fated attempt to bring saw
into a new dimension since then jigsaw
and spiral are the only saw movies we've
gotten saw X is calling back to the
original films of its title and by
placing its story right back in the good
old days of the franchise
all the Saw movies end up in a grimy
Warehouse of one point or another
because that's where jigsaw sets up his
traps the movies haven't ever spent much
time exploring the city Beyond those
warehouses even spiral which spent more
time out in the daylight than any other
Saw movie never really clarified the
setting for all the incredible attention
to detail that saw Pace at the intricate
backstory of its main character and the
torturous trapsy invents the movies
never even tell us what they take place
don't expect that to be the case with
sore X the trend of setting location
agnostic stories is going out the window
with the franchise's latest installment
in the movie John heads to Mexico City
in search of cancer treatment and the
city is going to play a huge role in the
story saw X was shot on location in
Mexico City so we'll get to see all the
sights alongside Jon before the Trap
making gets underway taking John Kramer
to Mexico pulls a franchise out of the
US and into a specific location for the
very first time the change gives a movie
a chance to tell a new kind of story and
it thrilled the people who are working
on saw X speaking to fans of midsummer's
stream 2023 saw X production designer
Anthony stabley said for us from the
get-go we were already winning because
Mexico is so exotic and John Kramer's
like a fish out of water finally pushing
Jon into a space where he's not in
control let's fancy the character in a
whole new light also it makes for a
welcome change to the usual locations
where he lets his nefarious imagination
run wild director Kevin grout knows
exactly where the saw franchise has been
before and he wanted to use Mexico City
as fuel for telling a story that saw
fans haven't already seen previously
speaking at mid-summer scream 2023 he
said that's such a mythology the city is
so amazing we can't speak enough about
it and just that there's a certain
creepiness to it and a certain history
and it just absolutely worked for us
withstood the test of time
coming in it's one hour and 58 minutes
saw eggs is the longest film in the
series to date naturally that means
there will be enough time to show off
the real Main Attraction of the movie
and what everyone is here for the traps
as with every new Saw movie you can
expect saw X to be filled with brand new
hyper violence Contraptions the poster
for the movie already gives a hint of
what to expect it shows someone locked
into a set of creepy goggles that have
tubes connected to the eyes whatever the
device is meant to do watching it in
action will probably make you cringe
enough sympathy pains the official sawax
trailer also gives us a few brief
glances at Jon's inventions in the movie
it shows a group of people chained up
inside a classic soul Warehouse one
woman appears to have a saw blade set up
in front of her neck a panicked man is
strapped into some kind of modified
electric chair in a different shot we
can see a jigsaw puppet Wheeling out
surgical supplies to Jon's victims from
the little we've seen sore X looks to be
as gruesome as its predecessors
every time a series introduces a new
prequel the chances for retconning
Skyrocket altering a stories past is one
of the best ways to dramatically change
its future on the surface saw X seems
like a perfect opportunity for the soul
Cannon to reinvent itself maybe John
Kramer had a secret child or perhaps his
time in Mexico City gave him the perfect
strategy for faking his death at the end
of Saw 3 and he's been alive all this
time saw X could hit the restart button
for the franchise in any number of ways
but it probably won't if the franchise
really wanted to take things in a
different direction it probably wouldn't
be diving back into John Kramer's past
at all John has been dead for the
majority of the franchise's existence at
this point so retconning his death would
completely ruin the story of most of the
movies aside from Jon's death there's
really no big event in this series that
is even remotely asking for a retcon it
seems pretty safe to assume that sore X
is going back in time to just give us
another jigsaw story and it probably
won't do anything that impacts what the
rest of the series has already
established the latest installments
director Kevin grutert thinks that the
franchise could continue the blood is
not entirely sure how speaking to sfx he
said there's no obvious direction to go
after this film but I think there
probably will be more Saw movies
particularly if this one is successful
I'm long gone from this world
considering that the original saw came
out in 2004 there's now an entire
generation of moviegoers who missed out
on the franchise's Heyday Saw made
enough of a cultural impact that even
people who were young enough to miss
actually seeing the movie probably knew
a little about its premise there's an
extensive backlog of Saw movies for new
fans to brush up on but it's probably
not necessary to see them all before
showing up at the theater for sore acts
anyone who's looking for the bare
minimum catch of a story before sore
eggs should at least watch the original
movie
it takes place right before the events
of Saw X but to really get the full
context it's also worth watching sword 2
and saw 3 which carry the story through
to the death of John Kramer after that
watching Saw 4 all the way through to
jigsaw will give fans the fullest
possible picture of Jon's story and the
lives of The Killers he inspired beyond
that true completionists can check out
spiral if they haven't already